those fortunate enough to be given the
opportunity
to leave a rapidly dying earth knew
there would be a number of challenges
they would face
they understood that forging a new
future for humanity could potentially
come with a cost
to their lives but even then none were
prepared for the events that would occur
in this new world and one of these such
events
was the horrific civil war which
completely divided the colonists
and was responsible for countless deaths
but given that they were all fighting
for the same thing and they all
seemingly had the same goal
the survival of the human species what
could have possibly happened
that would turn them against one another
[Music]
after the anomaly storms hit the first
city there was massive amounts of damage
dealt to the initial infrastructure
throughout the colony
one notable component in particular was
the nuclear core
that was providing power to all of its
systems
following the collapse of the core and
energy production the decision on what
to do with the 400
000 civilians being kept alive and
cryopods had to be addressed
without power and the backup batteries
quickly running out
these souls were at risk yet the colony
was still not presently in a situation
where this many people could be
adequately supported
there wasn't enough food clothing or
housing
nevertheless the call was made to save
the people on life support
and introduce them into the world of
enoch
and so unsurprisingly within no time at
all the first city was overwhelmed
crude makeshift shacks were quickly
constructed outside the city walls
to temporarily house the people but
because of the sheer number of
individuals and cramped accommodations
and the limited resources available to
them this area rapidly evolved
into the slums of the new world colony
starvation disease and death was rampant
and it became a way of life for these
people who struggled to even get their
basic needs of survival met
eventually a second storm hit the region
thousands died
mostly within the slums of the first
city and the initial fear from these
storms
quickly turned into anger fighting and
looting became commonplace
and a number of gangs started to form
riots began
and started making their way towards the
central districts of the city
and while the eca forces were engaged in
handling the riots
a number of well-coordinated gangs
started raiding supplies
eventually the eca began the process of
focusing their resources on a new
establishment
at riftown although they insisted
otherwise
questions were beginning to be raised on
how this would impact the construction
of housing for the tens of thousands who
were still without a roof over their
head
and on top of it all the once timid
wildlife of a knock
having been transformed by the storms
were starting to attack
people and were becoming more dangerous
by the day
the eca were finding themselves in a
difficult position of having neither
numbers
nor the supplies to deal with the
increasingly hostile wildlife
along with the constant uprisings of the
population
eventually the council voted and it was
agreed upon that the city would close
its gates
essentially exiling those who were stuck
outside living in the slums
to begin with eca patrols attempted to
keep the peace outside the walls
and endeavoured to provide any rations
they could spare
but as the violence grew ultimately the
patrols eventually stopped
a group of individuals became
increasingly disheartened by the poor
efforts of the eca
and they began to believe that they and
the people of the slums
had been abandoned barred from the city
and pushed into the life of an outcast
these people decided to name themselves
the exiles
and although initially their protests
may have just been unorganized noise
they quickly grew to become a more
extreme and capable threat
with a number of random bombings and
unprecedented violence towards the city
the riots were beginning to get out of
control
the exiles or the insurgency as the eca
preferred to call them
started a number of skirmishes against
the official colony forces
but despite their numbers being
considerably larger than the eca army
their weapons training and discipline
was subpar
and resulted in the majority of their
early attacks being abruptly ended
before any real damage could be
inflicted but regardless
the eca decided the first city was a
lost cause
they decided to move the headquarters to
a more secure location
and although construction was still
incomplete at this time the new eca hq
would become rooftown
on all accounts it looked like the
insurgents uprising was beginning to
look like a failed cause
the eca had starved them with food water
and protection from the storms and
wildlife
that were ravaging the land they had
abandoned them
but suddenly for the first time a
potentially strong leader made
themselves known
and was successfully able to unite the
many exile groups
under a single leadership he helped
breathe new life into their cause
ignited their reasons for fighting and
brought their motivation to a new level
and on top of this the new leader was
rumored to have strange
and unnatural powers he was the first
individual to be called
altered this warlord ruthlessly launched
an all-out assault
against the eca establishment and armed
with his large army of insurgents
they marched upon the first city and
killed everything in sight
any remaining eca who hadn't yet left
the city for riftown
were unmercifully slaughtered the
insurgents took control of the first
city
and officially declared war on the eca
as more and more altered began turning
up within the insurgent ranks
the capability and threat of this group
only increased
and armed with their new powers they
were able to turn the direction of the
war in their favor
these people no longer had the same
goals as the former selves
they had lost parts of the humanity and
were becoming an alpha species of their
own
with powers of summoning fire healing
mortal wounds in seconds
and manipulating gravity the insurgents
were growing far beyond the control of
the eca forces
so the eca attempted to organise peace
the president even offered to meet with
their leadership
but the insurgents weren't interested in
peace they were far beyond peace
they only wanted blood hidden among
their leaders
was the first altered and when the
president of the eca came forward
and made himself known the altered
swiftly left forward
and assassinated him along with its
officials
following this the signal was given to
proceed with a full-scale attack on
riftown
the eca would have met its end that day
if it wasn't for a soldier within the
eca army
who stood up to the first altered as it
turns out
the soldier too was altered his name
was seth he proceeded to single-handedly
put a stop to the attack on riftown
and push back the insurgents over time
more altered also began emerging on the
side of the eca
but with most of the official eca
leadership now dead there was a pending
power struggle that could divide the eca
forces
having been around since the very first
landing shira guptman was put into the
role
of grand marshal and given control of
rift town
however there were many who didn't
recognise her leadership
a group led by victor corrigan moved
east and built a settlement known as
trenchtown
the quarry also made moves away from the
eca leadership but were later brought
under corrigan's control
shira spent the better half of the
following year fighting off attempts to
remove her from power
this resulted in frequently broken
ceasefires and in the year 2161
the endless war began a 30-year war
that continues to this day a war that
fights over ground that frequently
changes ownership
with no side coming out on top
at this point in time the original
colony numbers have dropped from half a
million
to less than 70 thousand entire
generations have been born into
and killed in war and the anomaly storms
have continued to grow in severity and
the native wildlife
are only growing stronger and more
deadly
but while all of this has been going on
the eca leadership has remained loyal to
the bigger picture
expeditions continued to be sent out
time and time again
to find a way out of the current
situation through the deadly forests
and out the other side where hopefully
there would be an area on the planet
away from the storms that could provide
something better
something humanity could call home
in 2184 porrigan and shira officially
united under the eca banner
in an attempt to combat the growing
insurgent threat as a combined effort
though they would continue to keep the
affairs of the individual regions
under their own control this war that
started in 2161
was given the title of the endless war
but this wasn't because of the length of
time that has passed
more because of the pure rage that fuels
every decision to attack the other side
it is because of the sheer desperation
that drives people to survival
at any cost because of the propaganda
that is forced onto the children raised
on either side of this war
within the trenches and the front lines
of this ongoing conflict
the reality is clear to everyone
involved there will be no end to this
war
unless one side is completely eliminated
[Music]
through even just a handful of journal
entries the story gains a hell of a lot
more depth
and as you'll see in a video coming up
it gets pretty damn dark
too in a way the story of outriders is
an example of how the human species
regardless of how much we think we've
evolved and learned over the years
when pushed to the limits of survival
would likely continue to repeat the same
mistakes that we've made time and time
again
throughout our short history
anyway thank you very much for watching
i hope you've enjoyed this and i'll
catch you in the next one
cheers
[Music]
you